you've been blessed in your career
clearly but it must be getting old that
everywhere you go I'm sure people ask
you about a friends reunion it's just
got to do how do you deal with that oh
well first of all I think it's great
that you know the show still kind of
holds up you know it's on all the time
everywhere it's kind of great but and
also new generations keep discovering it
yeah wow this is great and then they
watch it as if they had never seen it
before what he said yeah
but the friends reunion question is
funny I guess it depends on my mood you
know sometimes I'll say no no yeah that
ship is say oh that's not gonna happen
you know it was about a finite period of
time in people's lives and blah blah
blah then sometimes I'll say it was on
last night you missed it it was really
great man awesome where were you yeah
there was an orgy at the end yeah
incredible yeah yeah yeah now I'm just
curious about this the other thing you
are so identified with Joey Tribbiani do
you ever have fans come up to you and
maybe think that that's who you are as a
person yeah you know it's funny it
doesn't happen as much anymore what
happens now is people who say go wow
you're so Oh came up to me on the street
news like hey are you weave Joey's dad
okay but when when when the show was on
like in primetime frozen reruns and it
was like a big phenomena thing yeah
people would like when I would meet
people they would speak really slowly
and I don't know if that's you know I'm
doing a good job and then yeah I think
you sold them on that character you
should be happy yeah how are you yeah
you all right okay we're gonna eat now
exactly some soup Oh Oh big a lot of
[ __ ]
you